I have like buy this more for yourself
yeah yeah I just I I'm not really into
like my body
I know me too I don't I don't like my
body no bro are you kidding me dude
after this thing I'll take off my
clothes and I look like a substitute
teacher and I got a fat ass okay
absolutely dude it's like a cafeteria
ass welcome to stupid questions with
Krista Stefano we are in Los Angeles
good city Kim Kardashian avocados gang's
all that and what with Brian Moses I
want to do some stupid questions that
under the theme of roasting okay if you
could roast anybody like ever in life
like in history who would you roast
Andrew Jackson you want to roast Andrew
Jackson from the 20 yes why because he
was like people say he was a race'
though I think was more than that he was
just a man about money right right yeah
and then I would go for that be like oh
you didn't make any money because he's
like he's like Trump in that way yeah
well you know what the interesting part
about roasting somebody like that is
because he that wouldn't understand the
rule so you would be roasting how many
time you just take out a shotgun and
shoot
yeah like get this slave out of here
yeah why is he talking
here's just do the question would you
rather marry the first person you had
sex with mm-hmm or the first person you
kissed uh and the first was I sex with
is bipolar
so probably her probably her yeah it
could be more interesting I like to be
stimulated a little time first person
hired sex with I was 17
okay and 17 yeah she was great
I have to make it half Italian you'd
like the diversity love it dude yeah
don't ever do why not
no she came over and she like rang the
bell he's like is your mom home and I
was like no that's she she was like you
want to have sex I was like no I bet
you're like wha morning I was like oh
boy so we walked up the stairs I
remember and they laid down I lay down
yeah and then I just couldn't get it up
and she punched me in the chest no I
swear to God if I did it that did it
yeah some some kind and that's still to
this day of like these aggressive things
I'm gonna kill someone
whoa be a worst punishment for never
being able to see the ocean again we're
never being able to watch TV again
Wow yeah there are the greatest of
questions than history's wild gosh I
bring the heat you know watching TV I
love TV you love TV this shows on TV
won't be able to see you took questions
about yeah it's not TV it's on the
Internet
but you don't care about the ocean then
you know I can see it on TV that's true
you can see it on TV yeah so I wanted
I'm good with you I don't need the ocean
I also think my dad's probably dump
people's bodies and there's some natural
can
okay this right here this is a stupid
question if you were a school
what were your colors be and what were
your mascot being we'd be the Foxes okay
yeah because foxes are cunning and
they're kind of sexy
yeah and we'd be orange and green cool
yeah I like that only the green kind of
like the hurricane if I was a school
what my colors be my colors will
probably be just the colors of the
Italian flag and then the brand and then
and then the mascot would just be a
garlic not running and rolling around no
it's a good part stupid questions is
that the end you get a stupid gift
really how'd you get me Bryan Moses
that's your name de Stefano yours right
so we got you 10 commandments on DVD
baby Moses Moses and I apologize for him
being a white I just think you know
that's just
I really appreciate that's what the
movie was back in the day I just think
like you represent new Moses we should
make new Commandments let's make new
commandment let's do it so what's what's
the first commandment thin Commandments
well what's the first commandment in
general thou shalt not is a kid on us my
mother if my mother is watching this
yeah I literally have the rosary beads
tattooed on my arm I don't know the time
you